First of all,
I wear my seatbelt.
Uh,
it is
changed my personal habits in a way that
I think are important.
Uh,
I think it has a
more fundamentally given me a
perspective on life,
uh,
that each moment that we're given is an
important one.
Then you want to use those,
uh,
moments,
as,
as ably as you can,
whether it's with your family or your
friends or,
um,
in your,
in your working life,
in all aspects.
Uh,
uh,
try to,
to seize the moment because those can
come to an end at any point in time.
Um,
life is a,
is a real luxury,
uh,
that one shouldn't take for granted.
So philosophically,
spiritually,
um,
I think I've grown,
by the experience and,
uh,
I guess the last thing I know is that,
is that,
um,
I always knew that you had to do things
or things where we're not always of your
own creation.
I'm alive because a lot of good people
help me get a chance to be alive in a
certain city in,
in the circumstances that evolved.
And if they hadn't been there,
um,
I could have been the smartest guy.
I could have been the richest guy.
I could have been anything.
It still wouldn't be alive.
Uh,
it's because a lot of other people make
things happen that I think all of us
have a chance to be a happy,
successful,
um,
be who,
yeah.